-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
We got a great one tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We got a great show tonight.
Guys, it is fall
in New York City,
and temperatures this week
are expected to hit 80 degrees.
So goodbye, lattes.
Hello, pumpkin-spice Slurpees.
Yeah!
A lot of people are talking
about this, you guys.
Mike Pence is still
on the campaign trail,
and he recently held an event
at a pizzeria in Iowa,
and only 13 people showed up.
Can we see a photo? Ooh. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It...
It's never a good sign
when all of your followers
can be fed by two pizzas,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
You know you had a bad showing
when you were drowned out
by the sound of someone
deep-frying garlic knots.
You can tell the campaign
isn't going well
because Pence also grabbed
a job application.
Yeah.
While he was there,
Pence ordered his favorite
pizza slice --
a plain pie
without sauce or cheese.
[ Laughter ]
And Pence also spoke
to some supporters
at an Iowa drug store.
Take a look at this photo.
This is real sad.
I mean...
Looks like he's going after that
all-important empty-chair vote.
It's just -- He was so dull
that they moved him
to the sleep-aid aisle.
It's so sad. I mean,
look at this guy right here.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He's sitting there like,
"How do I say this
in the most polite way?
I'm just here for the flu shot.
I mean, I don't want
to insult the guy."
[ Applause ]
"I'm not here for this.
I don't want to be rude."
Also, can we zoom in
on the guy's shoes?
Look at --
Look at the guy next to him.
He's like, "So you're wearing
the olive-green shoes
and black socks?
I'm gonna do olive-green socks
and black shoes.
So we don't match.
I don't want to match."
Some more political news.
Over the weekend, nine
Republican congressmen announced
that they are running
for Speaker of the House,
and they all released statements
saying
why they're right for the job,
but a few of the candidates
stood out to me.
-Really?
-Yeah, well, first up,
Austin Scott of Georgia said...
[ Laughter ]
[ Mutters ]
Tom Emmer of Minnesota said...
[ Laughter ]
Pete Sessions of Texas said...
I just --
They stood out to me.
-That's what he said.
-He stood out to me.
These quotes. Yeah.
And then Kevin Hern
of Oklahoma said...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-That's what he said.
And, finally,
Jack Bergman of Michigan said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
I don't know.
Well, it's been 20 days,
and the House is still locked
in a never-ending search
for a new Speaker,
but I think there may
finally be a solution.
Check this out.
-If you're looking
for a House Speaker,
then look no further!
Introducing the Amazon Alexa
House Speaker.
It can vote on bills.
-Alexa: Yay. Nay.
-It can heckle the President
during the State of the Union.
-Alexa:
Let's go. Brandon.
-And it can lose its job
after just a few weeks.
-Alexa:
I barely unpacked my stuff.
-Yeah. That's amazing.
That's cool.
[ Applause ]
Well, some business news.
Tesla just issued a recall
on 55,000 vehicles
over an issue with the brakes.
Yeah, an issue with the brakes.
You know,
when it comes to brakes,
you pretty much either have them
or you don't, and...
Well, listen to this.
I heard that, in Turkey,
Uber is now offering
hot air balloon rides.
I think that's great because
every time I'm in Turkey,
I always have a hard time
hailing hot air balloons.
"Hey..."
[ Applause ]
I think it's gonna be fun.
It's like, "Hey, is that --
I think I see you over there.
I'm just -- I'm the small dot
on the other corner.
I think I..."
Some TV news.
Netflix just released
the official trailer
for their upcoming reality show,
"Squid Game: The Challenge."
Critics are saying it's just
like "The Golden Bachelor"
because you spent all season
hoping your favorite character
doesn't die off.
Oh. Come on. Hey!
That's not...
-Hey! Wow!
-"Oh, no! Rose!"
-"Oh, God!"
-Did you guys see this?
A wax statue of
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson
has gone viral
because people say
it doesn't look
anything like him.
I don't know. Here. Take a look.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
There it is.
Well, a lot of people
have spoken out about it,
including The Rock himself.
He said...
Then he said...
Then this wax statue
of Prince William said...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Then this wax statue
of Leonardo DiCaprio said...
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
-What?
-Oh, my God.
-But then this statue of
soccer star Cristiano Ronaldo
spoke up and said...
[ Laughter ]
Then this old statue
of Lucille Ball said...
Then this old plaque
of Elvis Presley said...
And finally this wax statue
of Pope Francis said...
There you go. And that's true.
That's nice that he said that.
♪ You ain't nerthin'
bert a hernderg ♪
[ Laughter ]
Oh, he ain't nerthin'
bert a hernderg.
[ Laughs ]
Guys, this is wild.
Last night,
after landing at JFK Airport,
a JetBlue plane tipped backward
onto a wheelie --
into a wheelie.
Take a look at this thing.
-Ooh.
-The pilot was like,
"Sit, JetBlue. Sit. Good plane."
On the bright side,
the passengers in coach
got to eat all the peanuts
that rolled down
from first class.
Guys, if you saw me kind of
limping on the way out here,
I got in a bike crash yesterday.
-What?!
-Or an accident.
But I'm fine. But --
It was just me.
No one else was involved, but...
But I was --
I was riding my bike.
I went to a park
with my daughter,
and I go, "Let's go for
a bike ride. That'd be good."
I haven't ridden my bike all --
well, ever.
So I go, "Whatever.
I can figure it out. It's easy."
And so I kind of got cocky
and I go, "Well, you know what?
Maybe I'll just videotape
Winnie because it's cute."
-Yeah.
-I just want to -- For memories,
just to watch her on a bike
and Dad and his daughter.
And so, first of all,
that's a mistake.
-Yeah.
-You're taking the risk.
-One-handed.
-As soon as you
pull out that phone.
-Yeah. So I go,
"Well, this should be good."
And then I started
picking up speed.
I go, "This is getting nasty."
And I go -- Well, normally
I would use this brake
because that's the back wheel.
-Right.
-And if you do this one,
you'll flip forward.
-Yeah.
-So I don't know what to do.
I could toss the phone.
Which I should have done.
-Right.
Or put it in your pocket.
-I could have put it
in my pocket, yeah.
I got to go biking with you.
Yeah. No.
I go -- Well, I'll just do it
but softly pull the thing.
So I go...
[ Laughter ]
So I go to do it softly.
I'm not kidding.
The handlebar --
The left grip handle --
I don't even know
what you call this thing.
Comes off.
-In your hand?
-Spins like it's made
out of clay or something.
Bends like I'm Superman
or something.
I'm doing the thing, I spin it,
I flip the bike over.
And I just go,
"I'm okay, I'm okay."
Winnie kept going.
She didn't see Dad...
-She -- Yeah.
-And she was like,
"What happened?"
I go, "Oh, my gosh, dude."
I'm totally beat up.
I'm scraped.
There's blood everywhere.
You know what's even sadder?
-What?
-Oh, it's so sad. I thought
it'd be cute if I had, like,
a little, like,
a treat or something.
Me and Winnie
could go stop somewhere.
I put -- I had two apples
in a fanny pack.
[ Laughter ]
It was just applesauce
by the time...
[ Sad tuba plays ]
The accident.
The crime scene was just
applesauce everywhere and me.
-Do you have footage of it?
[ Drum roll ]
-So I go --
She goes, "What happened?"
I go, "Let's check the tape."
I actually have it.
It's fine, but it's pretty --
It's just more sad
than anything.
-Lucky you didn't have, like,
Swarovski crystals
in your pocket.
-No, I didn't.
[ Laughs ]
I don't -- I don't go bike
riding with Swarovski crystals.
-You never know.
-Yeah. Okay.
I guess you're right.
But just --
Anyways, here it is.
Do I need volume?
Probably not. Anyway...
Can you see it?
Sorry.
So now I start picking up speed.
Right around here, I go,
"Oh, I got to hit the brake.
I got to hit the..."
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
-Whoa!
[ Applause ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Oh, my Lord!
-Whew.
-Wow!
-Flipped. FFTEW! Yeah.
-How much road rash do you get?
-It's --
All my tattoos are gone.
-Are you serious?!
-Anyways, I'm fine.
And I'm just saying --
Here's the silver lining.
Don't --
The point of the thing.
Don't ever videotape while
you -- You take that risk.
Don't ever do that.
Yeah, but the other point?
Get back on that bike.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And wave all the way home!
You can go down,
but you got to get back up!
Guys, it's time
for our latest installment
of "Tonight Show" polls.
Here we go.
-♪ "Tonight Show" polls ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love -- I love these --
I love these
because they're informative and
I love polls and I love math.
-Yeah.
-And I just want to get
to know the the world.
-What people think, yeah.
-Yeah, Americans, New Yorkers,
anything.
I just love -- I'm interested.
-Wow.
-So that's why we do
the "Tonight Show" polls.
-Very scientific.
-Yeah, but they're
fun questions.
They're very, very interesting.
Everyone wants to know
about these polls.
The first poll says,
"What is your favorite sport?"
-Wow.
-40% said, "Football."
-Whoa.
-30% said, "Basketball."
20% said, "Baseball."
8% said, "Formula 1."
2% said, "Depends on which one
Taylor shows up at."
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Their favorite sport.
-Favorite, favorite.
-Good sport.
This next poll said,
"What is the best way
to get out of a costume party?"
-Oh.
20% said, "Say you're sick."
20% said,
"Say you're out of town."
60% said, "Say your dressed
as the Speaker of the House
and just don't show up."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Great costume.
-Great costume.
This next poll asked, "What is
the scariest thing ever?"
-Ooh.
-Baby boomers said,
"The cost of healthcare."
[ Laughter ]
Gen X said, "Serial killers."
Millennials said, "Zombies."
Gen Z said,
"Getting a phone call."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ohhh!
-"Dude, I'm freaking out, man!
No!"
-"Coming from inside my phone!"
-"Aaah!"
[ Laughter ]
Next poll asked,
"What's your favorite cheese?"
-Oh, I love cheese.
-25% said Cheddar.
25% said Gouda.
25% said Itz.
-Oh!
-25% said balls.
-Oh! Ew.
Balls.
-Yeah.
Next poll said...
-That go in a cheese sack?
-..."Why did you move in
with your partner?"
That's a cheese head?
-Yeah.
[ Rim shot, chord plays ]
Next poll asks, "Why did you
move in with your partner?"
10% said, "It's convenient."
20% said, "We plan
on getting married."
70% said, "Because Netflix
won't let you share passwords
anymore."
"That's why we're together."
-Come on, true love.
-This next poll asked,
"How do you feel right now?"
20% said, "Eh."
20% said, "Meh."
60% said, "Bleh."
[ Applause ]
Next poll asked,
"What do you do all day?"
20% said, "Slay."
20% said, "Be cray."
60% said, "Hey,
you just did that joke
and it wasn't funny
the first time."
[ Rim shot, chord plays ]
-What?
Wait. What? What?
-"Eh," "Meh," "Bleh."
They heard it, yeah.
-They consider those
similar jokes.
-Yeah, similar jokes.
-A rhyme joke.
-This last one asks, "What is
the best part of Halloween?"
10% said, "Horror movies."
10% said, "Haunted houses."
10% said, "Spooky costumes."
70% said, "The fact CVS already
has their
Christmas displays up."
There you go.
That's all the time we have
for "Tonight Show" polls.